there is a version of Doom or OG
Wolfenstein starring Keanu Reeves hidden
inside of cyberpunk 2077. this was
posted by virus man on the cyberpunk
subreddit and it shows a full arcade
console complete with doom Style music
called arasaka Tower where you the
player as Johnny silverhand after like
try and take down our soccer ball I love
it so much all the sound effects
everything it looks a little more like
Wolfenstein than Doom to me but like
what a cool thing to include in the game
I wonder how in depth it gets and you
even see like Johnny silverhand's little
face moving in the middle of the screen
as it should assume 93 is my favorite
video game cyberpunk 2077 is also one of
my favorite video games combining the
two of them is just like a dream come
true but they're all levels that look
slightly different as you get deeper
into the building and then there are
like heavy enemies as you get further in
as well that just take a few more shots
to take down as they should I love it
what a cool inclusion